You've been able to play incredible roles.
And you've played fun roles and a lot of, should we say a
bit shy, bad guys.
I really like bad guys!
No one wants to do prince charming, everyone
wants to do the villain.
But what is it with you that allows for you
to get these parts, what do you yourself think
it is about you appearance that makes you
get them?
Three things: Ha-ha!
Timing.
When started in the beginning of the 80s,
everyone was protesting outside
the movie production companies.
That they weren't portraying minorities.
Like latinos, black people, arabs or asian people, they
were always playing the bad guys.
They were always crooks.
So in the end, Hollywood gave up and said: ÇLet's
go back to doing Russians and GermansÈ.
Because they'll never protest!
As they did in the 40s, 50s and 60s.
So the timing was good.
So a producer ... and producers are so stupid!
They could call and you could get a question
like: ÇI'm sure you can speak Hungarian, right?È
ÇYes!È I said. ÇThat's no problem!È
You know, there's one line in Hungarian.
Those of you who've seen American movies.
Some star enters and says something like ... *Attempts
to speak Hungarian.*
And then the other one  says: *ÇHungarianÈ* Before someone says: ÇLet's continue in English.È
And then they continue the conversation in
English, it's a little twisted.
But that's how you do movies here.
So I like doing a little ... I come from the
theatre, and there you do a lot of strange characters.
Whereas in your private life, you try to be
normal.
And it's always a good time.
I'm thinking about accents ... If you were
to ...
It's interesting how Americans think that Europeans, in general, can be so extremely horrible.
Mhm.
If you, right now, were to ... I just want
to see how I would feel ...
If you now threatened me ...
In a couple of different accents, European ones.
Just ...
OK, I'll do two.
Yes, do two, a little tough.
Yes.
I will do one ... With a Norwegian accent,
he's not gonna be scared.
ÇHello!È
ÇNice looking guy!È
ÇI think I'm gonna cut off your balls!È
ÇAnd then eat your brain!È
It feels ... It's just pleasant!
It's just a pleasant little chat about ...
But if you go further east ...
ÇEy, you good looking guy!È
ÇI'm gonna rip off your balls, then I think
I'm gonna eat your brains.È
Please don't.
I've read that you've said that you're four
people in this elite club who get these parts ...
... the really good villain parts in Hollywood.
And you've mentioned ... You've mentioned
Malkovich, you've mentioned Dafoe ...
... and you've mentioned Christopher Walken.
Yes.
And I thought that we'll ... Get it in ... I
thought that we could do the villain top list.
Now we'll decide, we'll just rank them! And you yourself will rank ...
So here we've got Willem Dafoe, John Malkovich, Christopher Walken and Peter Stormare.
And I don't think is the final ranking according
to you.
I just have to check that he's not in here.
OK.
So ...
In a shared second place, a little below ...
There's still a little Scandinavian modesty left in you?
No, there isn't!
Right.
But here we've got Christopher Walken as a
Bond villain.
Have you never wanted that part?
I turned it down once.
You did?
Can I say something?
Yes.
Now it's not an option anymore.
But ...
I've never understood James Bond!
I think it's the lamest thing ever!
Excuse me!
Is that why you turned it down?
I probably had other offers that were better ...
... and to to the same, you know ...
ÇYeah mister Bond, I'm gonna kill youÈ ...
And then ...
Everyone in the audience knows, he's not gonna die, that bastard!
You don't stand a chance!
No!
To me, James Bond's formula is boring.
It's ... Partly, I don't like cars.
Partly, I don't like watches and fancy things.
I have no urge to se anything that's paint
by numbers.
He always survives.
I'm sitting here talking about you like you're
a bad guy, but you're really a kind man?
And as I understood, you were a kind boy when
you grew up in Norrland in Sweden?
I was often alone.
I often sat in the locker room with glow in
the dark colours and dreamt about moving to ...
the U.S., even when I was only five years old.
And I had a premonition, I knew that I was
gonna end up living here ...
... already when I was five, as I told my parents.
They said: ÇAre you gonna live in the U.S.,
what are you gonna do there?È.
And I said: ÇWell, I don't know, but I'm
gonna live close to Disneyland and hopefully,
I'll be working with moviesÈ.
Your parents left your home before you did,
is that correct?
My dad was always traveling, he was an inventor.
And I think that's why we had a few difficulties
with being in Sweden and the taxes in Sweden.
He paid like 112 percent tax of his pay check some years, and that made him resent Sweden,
he wanted to get out, so they moved.
They were quite a bit in the U.S. ...
... a lot in the U.K., a lot in Germany where they traveled around with their inventions.
And at the same time, he worked for two different
companies in Sweden.
And in the end, he just said ÇI've had enough
of this shit.È
ÇWe're going to Nigeria.È
Nigeria?!
Nigeria.
I think I was around 16 years old.
And I thought ÇI had to finish school, so
I'll just come visitÈ.
So they just came one day and said that you
were moving to Nigeria?
He took me to the sauna and said it.
Naked and vulnerable, you were sitting there
and receiving this message?
Yes.
He was a lot in the sauna, you know.
So we were sitting in the sauna, me being
16 years old, maybe 17, I had just started high school.
ÇI've decided that we're moving to Nigeria.È
ÇNigeria?È
ÇThat's quite far away.È
And it was far away in the 70s.
I asked what he was gonna do there.
ÇI'm gonna construct roads and do shit.È
ÇIt's a really good job. And you can't work in this country anymore.È
ÇAre you joining or do you wanna finish school?È
I just thought ÇI wanna play soccer and drink
beer and meet girls!È
So I didn't think that Nigeria sounded all
that great.
So I stayed at home and took care of our little croft.
And they left.
Could you say that the U.S. ended up being
your Nigeria?
I'm happy in this country, absolutely.
But I loved growing up in a forest in HŠlsingland.
My hometown ArbrŒ.
There were no dangers there.
We'd just go into the woods or run around.
What do you miss the most Ð Sweden or Norrland?
After so many years, you don't really miss
anything.
I miss my home in Los Angeles.
And then ...
This country is so fantastic, even in Los Angeles, you can drive for two and a half hours and you'll get to ...
Norrland.
With forests and brown bears and ... Or, black
bears are the ones that are there.
But it really reminds me of Norrland.
Is the mentality Norrland-like as well?
Yes!
People are a bit lawless and just do what
they want.
There aren't that many cops, you know.
Ha-ha!
And this is where you're the most happy?
Yeah, it's cool.
I mean, I love ordinary people.
I'm from an environment full of very ordinary
people.
I feel sorry for people in small places in
Sweden when I see how everything's falling apart.
And I love regular people.
Who are ordinary people and unpretentious.
Which is why I could never live in Beverly
Hills or go to parties or doing stuff like that.
I despise people who are very pretentious and ...
... who want to flaunt how much they have, or how much they earn and stuff like that.
There are those who buy houses and brag about it in Los Angeles, where I live.
That the house cost 47 million dollars.
And they're gonna renovate for 25 million.
And I think to myself Çwhat a fucking idiotÈ!
I'm not at all impressed, I just think less
of you!
I read that when you were a boy, you were
a believer?
Yes.
With the bible in your hand.
Are you still, today?
Do you still have faith?
No bible!
There's no bible, but I've got this.
This can be sufficient sometimes.
Religious little trinklets.
But ... The first book I ever got was probably
the bible.
And I'm not sure why.
Why I got the bible.
But I walked around with the bible under my
arm, and I went to our neighbors and I said ...
... that I had to bless their food.
But my mother and father thought it was very
embarrassing.
But they let me do it.
Because the neighbors thought it was nice
that I stopped by and blessed them now and then.
But ... I was born with a faith, I was born
with a faith, and it's strange, because I ...
... often sat by a window at home where we lived
and looked towards the hill nearby and ...
... it felt like I lived there.
It was almost like I entered down there by
chance, and I said to my parents that ...
... I wanted to go home, that I didn't really want to be
there, Çyou're not really my parentsÈ.
They were probably a little scared that I
was mentally disturbed ...
But I never did anything wrong, I just sat there and daydreamed.
And it's always been there with me, a voice
that sometimes can lead me astray ...
... but 99 percent of the time, it leads me to the right
place.
So, what does your spirituality look like
today?
My spirituality ...
Do you think there's life
after death?
Of course, there is.
At least for me.
Or else, we wouldn't be here.
And go through this strange journey on earth.
To me ... To me, it's all obvious, but it's
hard to explain.
It's so obvious to me.
If I were to try to describe it with words,
I don't think there are any word's that'll cover it.
But if you don't believe or if you haven't
seen or experienced ... Then you might as well not believe.
Because it's pretty boring to live if you
don't believe.
And sometimes they ask me Çdo you believe
in UFOsÈ or Çdo you believe in aliensÈ?
And I say Çwhy not?È.  My life is much more fun if I believe in all that.
... than if I don't believe.
And I've seen people ... I've seen ghosts, I've seen things, I've seen miracles in my life that are wonderful.
And that is probably because I believe that
everything is possible.
Peter, before we continue ...
I have to show a clip from you new show ÇSwedish DicksÈ.
And I'm saying ÇSwedish DicksÈ, and it sounds
a bit rude, but it isn't really that bad?
No.
It's an old name that's a bit playful.
Humphrey Bogart was always a Çprivate dickÈ and
it's ... It's an old word for ÇdetectiveÈ ..
... that people just abbreviated. ÇI'm a private dickÈ.
And you've stated that this is the first time
you can watch yourself on TV without feeling unwell?
Yes!
Yes! I think the character is so funny ... It's
a guy who thinks that he knows everything ...
... but he's so lost.
Especially when it comes to digital stuff.
He thinks that he has a clue, but he doesn't.
But he's honest and he manages to accomplish
everything.
I've got a small scene her, can we show it?
Yeah, yeah!
Have a look at this.
Bring him back.
BRING HIM BACK!
He's a stubborn spirit, I can't!
I need something stronger!
Like what?
Well, okay, there are these candles.
They're made out of Bolivian salt, and the
ancient Mayans used to use them, but they're ...
really expensive.
How much?
300.
Peter Stormare, thank you so much for being
here!